termina la fuga de Mateo messina de naro
El capo mafioso más buscado de Italia
llevaba 30 años huyendo a la justicia
italiana considerado la cabeza de cosa
nostra La temida Mafia siciliana las
primeras informaciones indican que fue
detenido en la ciudad de Palermo en
sicilia en una clínica privada
especializada en oncología según el
comandante de la unidad de carabineros
que participó al operativo el mafioso
estaba sometiéndose a algún tipo de
terapia en esta clínica El capo no puso
resistencia cuando fue abordado por los
agentes medicina de Naruto había sido
condenado en ausencia a cadena perpetua
por decenas de asesinatos incluidos los
de niños y mujeres embarazadas participó
a los atentados más sangrientos de cosa
nostra en los años 90 en Italia masacres
de jueces policías periodistas atentados
en Milán Florencia y Roma para la
primera ministra del gobierno Georgia
meloni se trata de una Victoria para el
estado que demuestra que no se rinde
ante la mafia y los medios del país
hablan de un día histórico para i